all right so today joe delivered a
speech about building bridges after the
speech he gave earlier in the week
tuesday comparing all of his political
opponents to bull connor george wallace
jefferson davis while also referring to
tens of millions of americans as
domestic enemies
wow take a look
i know where i stand
i will not yield i will not flinch i
will defend the right to vote our
democracy against all enemies foreign
and yes domestic
so i ask every elected official in
america
how do you want to be remembered
at consequential moments in history
they present a choice do you want to be
the sign on the side of dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
this is the moment to decide
those remarks were so unhinged that even
joe's fellow democrats they were put off
even dick durbin said that biden went
too far nancy pelosi criticized joe for
evoking bull connor and strom thurman
and former congresswoman and democratic
presidential candidate tulsi gabbard
tweeted quote hillary calling tens of
millions of americans deplorables was
divisive and disgusting biden has gone
further calling those that disagree with
his actions and policies domestic
enemies traitors racists and biden did
promise to unite us but he is doing all
he can to divide us
tonight it appears that the only way joe
biden is uniting americans is against
joe biden and former congresswoman
kelsey gabbard joins us with more just
give your overall perception
of not only the speech
but this week and this year we're we're
just a few days away from the one-year
anniversary since he was inaugurated
yeah sean you know i think there were so
many people across the country those who
voted for joe biden those who did not
vote for joe biden who had high hopes
that he would carry out his promise that
he would be the president for all
americans showing respect for those who
agreed with him or disagreed with him
and unfortunately the opposite is true
not only has he not carried out on that
promise he is literally doing the exact
opposite rapidly carrying our country uh
in in the wrong direction tearing us
apart pouring fuel on the flames of
divisiveness
and it it just i mean it really makes me
wonder how
we can go through three more years of
this and still come out the other end
with the possibility of being able to
come together
again as americans as the united states
of america
look when you look at for example we ran
out of tests we ran out of monoclonal
antibodies we ran out of antivirals
inflation of 40-year high
energy 85 a barrel he's begging opec and
russia to produce more he inherited
energy independence his vaccine mandate
fell apart um the average american now
the inflation
of every american family is about five
thousand dollars per family it is
impacting
everybody but almost a buck fifty more
gallon for gas a thousand dollars more
to heat your home this year
uh you know everything we buy in every
store is costing more although bare
shells biden is trending because it's
everywhere
do you see as a democrat or any of these
policies working am i missing something
that's successful
well what i see is people are struggling
and you can understand how people are
frustrated and even angry at the fact
that our government is failing us and
one of the most disturbing things that i
see coming out of this administration is
how president joe biden has his attorney
general targeting americans as domestic
terrorists
for uh being quote unquote
anti-authority
and what is so extremely dangerous about
this sean is that the president united
states is the authority here in america
and so if our president is targeting
americans for being quote unquote
anti-authority what they're really
saying is you are an enemy of the state
if you are against the president or his
policies uh this is the foundation of
authoritarianism
and it's it the message that is received
by people at home is
if you're going to target me for being
against your policies as the president
there will be consequences and therefore
what are people to do shut up step back
and fall in line and this this is
unacceptable in our democracy and must
not go unchecked
the one thing he's never allowed
republicans even in the room republicans
were never included in bill back better
republicans were never
included in
voter integrity measures my measures i'd
like to see so we can have confidence in
results and integrity in the process are
simple voter id signature verification i
think chain of custody controls so we
make sure nobody can tamper with mail-in
ballots
i think we need updated voter rolls and
i think we need partisan observers all
sides get to watch the vote count up
close start to finish and i think we'll
have more confidence and results i don't
think illegal immigrants should be
allowed to vote either is there anything
wrong with any of those measures in your
view that i mentioned or would you
include some or or take some away
i think the point there sean is that the
fact that there were not
leaders members of both parties in the
room crafting this legislation is
exactly the problem so there should be
no surprise why there is partisan
opposition to it
um whether or not everybody would agree
on all of those things or even hey i
think there's opportunity to come to
agreement on 80 percent of those things
and still be able to move us
forward
as a country but that's the problem and
there are many different examples
unfortunately under this administration
where they've chosen to take a very
partisan approach and then even though
they're leaving out republicans from the
the crafting table the negotiating table
then they say well how dare you not
support our bill that we wrote without
any of your input any discussion any
respect or consideration and i mean this
is this is transparent this is
transparent the american people see
what's happening i think and and again
are so dissatisfied by it all right um
we always love having you on thank you
tulsi gabbard we appreciate you it's uh
refreshing to hear a time somebody
independent minded hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else